donald trump suavizó el tono y por
primera vez aceptó que habrá una nueva
administración sin mencionar que un
supuesto fraude en las elecciones le
arrebató su victoria como ha insistido
sin pruebas durante los últimos dos
meses ahora el congreso ha certificado
los resultados y la nueva administración
se inaugurará el 20 de enero mi enfoque
ahora se centra en garantizar una
transición de poder tranquila ordenada y
sin problemas su mensaje se dio a través
de su cuenta de twitter la cual había
sido suspendida por hacer publicaciones
incendiarias y en medio del repetido
llamado de congresistas demócratas e
incluso republicanos para que trump sea
removido de su cargo el mandatario ha
señalado de haber incitado al asalto
contra el capitolio el pasado miércoles
y aunque en otras ocasiones se negó a
condenar los actos de violencia
provocados por sus simpatizantes
esta vez calificó este acontecimiento
como un ataque atroz pero indignado por
la violencia de la anarquía y el caos
para aquellos que participaron en los
actos de violencia y destrucción
ustedes no representan a nuestro país y
para aquellos que violaron la ley usted
pagarán el aparente nuevo discurso de
trump llega a menos de dos semanas de
que finalice su mandato en los últimos
días no sólo ha crecido el número de
líderes republicanos que se niegan a
defenderlo sino también la lista de
funcionarios de su administración que
han optado por abandonar sus cargos